es ist die Nachricht des Abends oder
Scholz hat auf den Tisch gehauen und ein
Machtwort gesprochen alle drei noch
verbliebenen deutschen Atomkraftwerke
laufen erst einmal weiter nicht nur die
beiden in Süddeutschland sowie
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und die
Grünen es wollten es gerade erst
verabschiedet hatten auf ihrem Parteitag
sondern auch das im Emsland in
Norddeutschland so wie es die FDP und
die Vernunft und auch Bild es gefordert
haben bei mir im Studio ist
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer ja ja ein
Sieg der Vernunft trotzdem auch nur ein
Teil sieht muss man sagen ja man kann
von einem siekchen sprechen vollkommen
richtig das geht jetzt erstmal in die
richtige Richtung drei Kernkraftwerke
laufen weiter und die Entscheidung fällt
jetzt nicht erst im November oder
Dezember sondern sie fällt direkt jetzt
mit dem Oktober das bedeutet zum einen
Planungssicherheit aber warum nicht Sieg
sondern nur siekchen weil bislang
zumindest Olaf Scholz gesagt hat am 15
April ist Schluss dann sollen alle drei
Kern vom Netz gehen wir hören deutlichen
Jubel bei der FDP bei den
Führungsspitzen der FDP und bisher
totales Schweigen bei den Grünen bei den
Spitzen grünen da ist so etwas wie
Schockstarre eingetreten warum Jubel bei
der FDP weil sie natürlich wissen dass
möglicherweise die Situation im
kommenden Frühjahr gar nicht so viel
anders ist als die Situation aktuell und
Olaf Scholz gezwungen sein könnte die
Kernkraftwerke noch mal wieder
weiterlaufen zu lassen das wäre dann
ehrlicherweise die total Blamage die
politische total Blamage für die Grünen
die ja wie gesagt gerade erst auf ihren
Parteitag am Wochenende beschlossen
hatten genau dies eben das nur zwei
Kraftwerke weiterlaufen sollten und auch
das war ja schon etwas dass man im
Parteimitgliedern abbringen musste ja
Olaf Scholz hat heute deutlich gemacht
hat ganz wortwörtlich auch von seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz Gebrauch gemacht
dass er der Chef ist dieses Kabinetts
viel zu lange gab es ja Streit zwischen
Christian Lindner und Robert Habeck den
beiden Ministern die unterschiedliche
Dinge wollen in dieser akw-frage und der
Parteitag der grün ist in der Tat noch
nicht einmal oder etwas mehr als 24
Stunden hier der Beschluss also noch
nicht mal richtig trocken und trotzdem
hat Olaf Scholz SPD Kanzler den Grünen
mal ordentlich eine Watschen Verfassung
gesagt das was ihr da beschlossen hat
das interessiert mich nicht die Bohne es
geht hier um die Energiesicherheit im
Land und man kann das wirklich als
Frontalangriff auf die Grünen sehen was
der Kanzler heute Abend bekannt gegeben
hat gleichzeitig tut es der FDP
natürlich auch gut die bisher in den
letzten Landtagswahlen immer klatschen
bekommen hat zuletzt gerade in
Niedersachsen hat Scholz da auch
Rücksicht genommen auf die Ampel
Arithmetik vielleicht ich glaube Scholz
hat vor allem Rücksicht genommen auf die
Sicherheit auf die Energiesicherheit in
dem Land und hat einfach ganz klar
geschaut wo laufen wir hin wenn es darum
geht ganz ein zu sparen und wir wissen
dass das knapp ist dann kommt man nicht
umhin wenn man einfach mathematisch
rechnet dass man möglichst so viel
andere Stromproduzenten am Netz lässt so
geht und da gibt es halt drei
Kernkraftwerke und das schließt sich
einfach durch logisches Denken schon
nicht warum man diese Kernkraftwerke
ersetzen sollte ausschalten sollte um
dann Strom beispielsweise durch
zusätzliche Gaskraftwerke zu produzieren
also da hat Olaf Scholz einfach mal
gesagt da denken wir mal ganz logisch
und machen das mal so wie man das
fünftigerweise machen würde deswegen
bleiben die drei Kernkraftwerke erstmal
am Netz also die Nachricht des Abends
vielen Dank Jan Schäfer alle drei
Kernkraftwerke bleiben am Netz bis April
nächsten Jahres nicht bis 2024 sowie die
FDP ist gefordert hatte aber alle drei
so wie die Partei das wollte eine
Klatsche für die Grünen
[Musik]